et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
donc médecine de panneaux bonjour
bonjour merci beaucoup d'années à vous
mes et du val de marne président
du groupe la france un soumise à
l'assemblée nationale on est ensemble
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale bonjour stéphane bern et
bonjour stéphane qui dirige le bureau
parisien du journal ouest france on
commence par la guadeloupe puisque jean
castex a pris la parole hier à l'issue
de la réunion avec les élus de
guadeloupe réunion vision évidemment un
pour jean castex les manifestations se
multiplient pour lille sur l'île parfois
violentes une violence condamné avec la
plus extrême fermeté c'est ce qu'a dit
hier le premier ministre et l'appel au
calme et il annonce la création d'une
instance de dialogue est ce que pour
vous les réponses du gouvernement sur
les bonnes alors je crois qu'elles sont
insuffisantes mais d'abord peut-être
dire un mot sur ce qui se passe en
guadeloupe qui est à mon avis assez
terrible et ses terribles d'ailleurs que
le gouvernement réagisse maintenant
seulement alors que cela fait quatre
mois que trente organisations syndicales
notamment manifestent tous les samedis
ont écrit des lettres ont alerté il ya
eu des alertes de nombreux élus de
guadeloupe sur la situation en
guadeloupe met d'ailleurs en martinique
aussi qui est assez similaire sur cette
question là et on n'a pas écouté la
population guadeloupéenne on n'a pas
écouté les difficultés qu'il y avait
notamment sur la question de la
vaccination obligatoire des soignants
notamment sur le pass sanitaire est
assez injuste en guadeloupe la
vaccination obligatoire des défaillances
et oui mais qui sera un des points de
revendications très important de la
population et je crois que on n'a pas
assez pris en compte le fait que
notamment la guadeloupe mais les
antilles en général ont vécu le scandale
du chlordécone que ce scandale du
chlordécone a fortement entaché la
confiance dans la parole publique et
empoisonne encore les corps les eaux les
sols pour encore au moins 600 ans et je
crois que le gouvernement a eu tort de
vouloir décider tout seul de vouloir
passer en force sur des questions et je
crois que ce qui se passe en guadeloupe
et en martinique actuellement est la
preuve qu une politique autoritaire de
santé ne fonctionne pas nous avons un
d'adhésion aux politiques se dit qu'il a
fallu attendre que les manifestations
dégénèrent puisque c'est le cas depuis
une semaine pour que le gouvernement
apporte des réponses assez bien sûr bien
sûr et c'est ce que disent d'ailleurs
les syndicats c'est ce que je regrette
énormément nous ça fait des mois qu'on
est en train de dire au gouvernement et
notamment au président de la république
qui n'est pas possible de tout décider à
partir d'un conseil de défense on ne
sait même pas exactement qui est qui est
couvert par le secret défense sans
démocratie sanitaire vous avez vu que à
l'assemblée nationale nous avons voté
enfin pas nous mais ils nous ont fait
voter le fait que pendant huit mois et
demi ce qui est du jamais vu ils ont les
pleins pouvoirs sanitaires sans revenir
devant l'assemblée nationale je crois
que c'est une grave erreur que de se
passer de démocratie lorsque dont on est
dans une crise sanitaire et ce qui se
passe en guadeloupe est actuellement la
conséquence de l'impasse dans laquelle
la macro ni nous a mené mais ce qu'il ya
forcément pas des coups de regarder en
martinique par exemple où là aussi il ya
des appels à la grève générale et il a
aussi à des manifestations contre laval
la vaccination obligatoire des
gouvernements à décaler cette
vaccination obligatoire au 31 décembre
au 31 décembre prochain avec césar est
ce que quand même d une écoute de la
part du groupe dont il ya eu un rapport
de force il ya eu un rapport de force
qu'est ce qui s'est passé en martinique
pour qui décale il s'est passé que
l'intersyndicale des soignants s'est mis
en mouvement rejoint par l'inter
l'intersyndicale du port rejoint par les
agents edf rejoints par les taxis etc
etc donc en fait ce gouvernement
n'écoute que quand il y a un rapport de
force et c'est ça qui est problématique
c'est que il y a des raisons objectives
il y a une légitimité dans les
revendications qui sont portées par la
population antillaise en ce moment est
donc ce n'est pas possible d'ignorer ça
ce n'est pas possible de ne pas avoir de
dialogue y compris que ça soit avec tout
le monde que ce soit les élus qui
interpelle les citoyens les syndicats
tout le monde a été ignorée bien on
arrive dans cette situation absolument
terrible qu'on voit actuellement est-ce
qu'il ya que des revendications
sanitaires il n'y a pas que ça il ya
d'autres choses derrière est-ce que vous
pouvez nous en dire plus bien sûr bien
sûr aux fondus au fond du problème oui
bien sûr parce que je crois que c'est
une crise beaucoup plus profond mais
vous avez raison de le souligner merci
de me laisser en parler parce que en
fait finalement ce qu'il était il ya
quelques mois plus tôt pour une
commission d' enquête parlementaire sur
la question de l'eau que demandent les
guadeloupéens aujourd'hui le droit
d'avoir une vie digne ça fait des mois
que avec les 30 députés de la commission
denquête parlementaires de tous bords
nous demandons à ce que le plan orsec
eau potable soit déclenchée qu'est ce
que c'est le plan orsec au total c'est
ce qu'on utilise c'est un dispositif
qu'on utilise normalement lorsqu'il ya
une catastrophe du type une tempête qui
a détruit les réseaux d'eau ou je ne
sais quoi et qui permet de distribuer
des bouteilles d'eau en plastique aux
personnes qui n'ont pas d'accès à l'eau
en guadeloupe aujourd'hui en france en
2021 vous avez des enfants guadeloupéens
qui rate jusqu'à un mois et demi de
cours par an parce qu'il n'ya pas d'eau
à l'école vous avez des familles des
mamans avec des enfants qui reste une
journée une semaine deux semaines trois
semaines sans aucun accès à l'eau vous
avez des parents qui se lève à 3h du
matin pour essayer d'avoir le main
maigre filet d'eau pour essayer de
remplir des bidons pour en avoir c'est
une situation catastrophique et vous le
savez le premier des gestes barrières
c'est de se laver les mains est donc
dans une période de crise sanitaire bon
déjà c'est une question de dignité
fondamentale mais dans une période de
crise sanitaire c'est criminel dû
refuser que de déclencher ce plan orsec
eau potable nous l'avons proposé je ne
sais pas peut-être dix fois à
l'assemblée nationale sous toutes les
formes possibles et le rapporteur qui
était avec moi et monsieur servat qui
est de la république en marche qui est
par ailleurs président de la commission
pour les élus ultramarins donc il ya une
certaine position dans la république en
marche et bien ce gouvernement a
systématiquement ignorées cela eh bien
je crois que la paix revienne des choses
il dit moi je vais vous dire j'ai
compris le motif c'est que ça coûte cher
c'est que ça coûte cher parce que je
vais vous expliquer pourquoi est-ce
qu'on est dans cette situation là en
guadeloupe on est dans cette situation
là parce que lorsque vous prélever de
l'eau en guadeloupe 70% de l'eau
prélevée par en fuite c'est un
gaspillage d'eau énorme qui se
retrouvent sur la facture des usagers
bien évidemment puisqu'elle est quand
même potabilisée donc vous avez des
familles avec 5000 6000 euros de
factures qui se retrouvent avec des
factures absolument exorbitantes et donc
il faut investir on sait ce qu'on a vu
dans la commission denquête entre 1 et 2
milliards dans les réseaux d'eau et
d'assainissement
parce que les réseaux d'assainissement
sont aussi dans un état catastrophique
ce qui pose un problème de santé et donc
sur un milliard à 2 milliards il faut
commencer évidemment les travaux
d'urgence mais ça va prendre un peu de
temps à rétablir ses réseaux d'eau et
donc en fait finalement j'ai compris la
dernière fois puisque c'est un des
ministres qui est qui me l'a dit qu'ils
me disaient mais ça va prendre des
années eh bien oui si ça prend des
années qu'il veut distribuer de l'eau
pendant des années et je crois que on ne
peut pas on ne peut pas sur une question
de dignité aussi essentiel avoir
l'argent en tête c'est vraiment
je ne sais même plus lequel des
ministres a répondu sur cette question
et je vais réfléchir je vais vous
retrouver ça mais en tout cas c'était la
réponse du ministre qui était au banc à
ce moment là mais il ya une la question
de l'eau il ya la question de la vie
chère là on le sait on a on a vous
rendez compte guadeloupe chez les jeunes
c'est 60 % de chômage vous avez un taux
de pauvreté qui est deux fois plus élevé
en guadeloupe que ce que nous avons un
hexagone et finalement qu'est-ce qui
s'exprime là en ce moment en guadeloupe
c'est aussi des jeunes qui n'ont aucune
perspective qui n'ont aucune perspective
et qui demandent juste à ce qu'on les
traite avec dignité avec respect et qui
route nous nous sommes des français de
guadeloupe et donc nous voulons qu'en
tant que tel nous soyons considérés et
non pas mépriser et du coup envoyé des
unités du raid
pour la pour la désescalade c'est pas
forcément bien c'est pas forcément la
bonne réponse mais vous avez tout à fait
raison ce qu'il faut c'est de la
désescalade vous imaginez le message qui
est envoyé au à la population
guadeloupéenne lorsqu'on envoie des
unités spécialisées à la fois contre le
grand banditisme et contre le terrorisme
ça veut dire qu'on considère que
finalement le problème c'est la
population on a montré de la population
mais on en a on essaye de ne pas arriver
à cette situation a déjà un
nom alors qu'est ce qu'on fait qu'est ce
qu'on fait maintenant alors déjà je le
dis à la fois cc c'est ressenti comme
extrêmement violent cet envoi du du raid
et du gign je vais je vais commencer par
ça et ça montre qu'on a un gouvernement
qui me connaît que la répression comme
réponse aux crises qui sont amis alors
qu'est ce qu'on fait quand on est mené
dans l'impasse comme ça eh bien d'abord
on discute ça c'est la première des
choses est la deuxième des choses c'est
que et bien on répond aux revendications
qui sont portées donc oui il faut
arrêter avec et second parle sur
l'obligation vaccinale parce que l'om
est dit il faut convaincre plutôt que
contrainte il y a une raison c'est ce
qu'on voit en ce moment oui il faut
arrêter avec le pass sanitaire qui donne
une illusion de sécurité oui il faut
absolument redonner des moyens à
l'hôpital public dans des endroits où
l'hôpital est complètement exsangue à
tel point qu'un professeur qui avait été
aidé en guadeloupe a dit qu il parlait
de maltraitance sanitaire en parlant de
la guadeloupe donc il faut agir sur des
questions de deux des revendications
c'est ça qui va permet de calmer la
colère légitime aujourd'hui est donc
passé le panneau la cinquième vague qui
touchent donc tout le pays est ce qu'il
faut généraliser rapidement la troisième
dose pour tout ça c'est aux médecins de
le dire en tout cas moi je suis
complètement contre conques on lit 7,7
ce troisième dose au pass sanitaires je
crois que le patient terre donne une
illusion de sécurité d'ailleurs on le
voit bien avec ce qui s'est passé avec
monsieur castex et surtout surtout
surtout et ça c'est très important on
est en train de se priver de lounès il a
priori il a été contaminé par sa fille
non c'est pas ça que je voulais dire
c'est assez c'est maintenant c'est que
le vaccin certes protège contre les
formes graves permet d'être moins
contaminés mais le vaccin non j'sais pas
de contaminer ou d'autres contaminants
et donc la question n'a jamais dit le
contraire oui non mais la question du
coup c'est que monsieur castex le sait
lui-même mieux que personne maintenant
tout en lui souhaitant un bon
rétablissement c'est pas du tout ça la
question je ne souhaite à personne
d'avoir le coc vite dans le pays mais la
question c'est que il faut rétablir
immédiatement la gratuité des tests
parce que si vous ne remettez pas les
tests vous ne pouvez pas détecté qui est
malade ou pas dans notre pays et le
problème c'est que ce gouvernement a
tout mis autour du pass à l'inter et ne
met rien sur la question de la
prévention ça fait des mois qu'on
demande à ce qu'il y ait des
purificateurs d'air par exemple dans les
classes ça fait des mois qu'on demande à
ce qu'on organise les sociétés de
roulement ça fait des mois qu'on demande
à ce qu'on lève les brevets sur la
question des vaccins et moi je vous
alerte là dessus nous sommes dans une
épidémie mondiale nous sommes tous
d'accord là dessus donc s'il ya
troisième dose dans notre pays s'il est
un troisième dose ça veut dire que ça
sera des doses en moins pour les pays
pauvres qui ont déjà beaucoup de mal à
accéder aux vaccins donc il faut
absolument lever les brevets sur les
vaccins parce que sinon nous ne
sortirons jamais de cette crise
sanitaire en plus d'un manque de
solidarité évident avec les populations
notamment du sud vous venez d'évoquer la
gratuité des tests vous pensez que le
fait que les tests ne soient plus lourd
en bourse est systématiquement en france
fait quand on a on a une à une
sous-évaluation whitta de santé
sanitaire du match je crois moi je crois
que lorsque
vous devez payer par exemple 40 euros
pour faire un test et que vous êtes dans
une situation difficile comme le sont 10
millions de noms de nos concitoyens qui
vivent sous le seuil de pauvreté dans
notre pays cinquième pays le plus riche
au monde eh bien oui je crois que
l'argent peut être un frein au fait de
se tester et que nous n'avons aucun
intérêt à ce que des gens n'aillent pas
se tester et vérifier s'ils ont ou non
le coc vide et donc potentiellement
contaminent d'autres gens donc la
gratuité des tests est un outil
essentiel pour lutter contre l'épidémie
nous devons absolument remettre cette
gratte et gratuit pour les personnes
avec ce n'est pour les personnes pour
les personnes avec ordonnance un oui il
va y parler de leur maître pour tout le
monde c'est ce qu'on faisait avant et
donc et c'est absolument ça qu'il faut
remettre dans notre pays on va parler de
ce qui s'est passé hier du côté d'elle
non puisque emmanuel macron a donc
terminé sa tournée du côté des hôtes
france à amiens sa ville natale et on
entendu votre collègue françois ruffin
qualifié emmanuel macron de père noël en
campagne vous pour vous partager ces
moments vous leur télé ou gipi je crois
que en ce moment donc on a un président
de la république qui effectivement
candidat d'ailleurs je me demande quand
est ce qu'on va des comptes et son temps
de parole quand est ce qu'on va mettre
certains des frais sur sur ses comptes
de campagne et qui passe son temps en ce
moment à promettre des chèques en bois
par ci par là bon je vais je vais donner
un exemple très concret par exemple il
va à marseille il annonce qu'il va
mettre deux milliards sur la table
notamment sur les questions des écoles
des transports
quand vous regardez la réalité de ces
deux milliards vous avez 6 millions qui
vont effectivement aux écoles du budget
de l'état vous avez 32 millions qui vont
aux transports donc ça fait 38 millions
on est extrêmement loin des 2 milliards
et qu'est ce que c'est le reste de
l'argent et bien cédé près que la ville
de marseille va devoir rembourser et sur
beaucoup des annonces qui sont faites on
retrouve ce type d'annoncé de
communication qui est qu'ils sont faits
tout en distribuer les chèques en bois
comme ça donc oui je trouve que père
noël en campagne est une bonne
expression et je crois que il est plus
que temps de tourner la page de ce
quinquennat d' emmanuel macron qui a été
catastrophique beaucoup d aspects cd est
dans les outrances par exemple pour les
établissements de santé pour le
ferroviaire est ce que ça vous pouvez
leur projet mais oui mais écoutez là on
est à quatre ans et demi de mandat si on
prend la question de la santé emmanuel
macron c'est celui qui a été responsable
de la fermeture de 14 mille lits
d'hospitalisation complète dans cinq
mille 700 lits d'hospitalisation
complète en 2020 donc en pleine pandémie
c'est celui qui a demandé 4 milliards
d'économies à l'hôpital public c'est
celui qui a enlevé 14 milliards à la
sécurité sociale depuis le début de son
quinquennat enfin
sega qui a revalorisé le sachent et
comprennent et ensuite à dix ans et qui
au pied taux qui fait que les soignants
aujourd'hui sont toujours en deçà de la
moyenne en dessous de la moyenne des
toujours des rémunérations qu'elle a par
exemple offert oui non mais bon un
moment enfin vous rendez compte on a
supprimé 100 mille lits dans notre pays
en vingt ans donc la pente à remonter la
marche elle et elle est quand même
extrêmement haute et donc je crois que
il faut acter que la santé est un bien
commun et qu' il faut arrêter avec les
policiers les politicos terry terres qui
ont été faites et mené depuis des années
bien sûr qu'ils n'ont pas été menée que
par monsieur emmanuel macron qui ont été
menées dans lé quinquennat précédent
aussi mais je crois que les réponses qui
sont apportées ne sont pas à la hauteur
et donc il peut faire une campagne de
une campagne comme cela la réalité c'est
que monsieur macron lorsque des gens
étaient en grève de la faim comme
c'était le cas à saint-etienne du
rouvray ou à des moments où les
soignants manifester eh bien il les a
ignorés de il les a gazé et matraqué
donc je pense que la communication ça
suffit si vous entendez vous le
reprocher aussi un problème de timing
c'est à dire que on est trop proche de
l'élection présidentielle c'est plus le
moment de faire ce type d'annoncé pour
vous c'est ça en fait j'ai l'impression
moins que emmanuel macron considèrent un
peu que l'élection présidentielle est
une formalité administrative donc on
nous fait la france de la stratégie
france 2030 on nous fait pendant huit
mois et demi donc des pleins pouvoirs à
l'exécutif sur les questions sanitaires
dont qui dépasse même la question de la
présidentielle et des législatives pour
aller jusqu'au 31 juillet et je pense
qu'il serait bien de rappeler à monsieur
emmanuel macron qu'il a été président
pendant quatre ans et demi et donc on ne
peut pas faire exactement le contraire
vous dire exactement le contraire de ce
qu'on a mené comme politique pendant
quatre ans et demi c'est à dire tout
pour les riches et des miettes pour les
autres est la deuxième des choses c'est
qu'il ya une élection présidentielle est
que cette élection présidentielle elle
se joue sur des femmes et des hommes qui
vont se déplacer le 10 et le 24 avril et
que c'est uniquement eux qui ce jour là
puisque j'ai une hygiène souveraineté du
peuple dans notre pays qui décideront
qui sera le ou la prochaine présidente
de la république et moi j'espère bien
que ça sera monsieur jean-yves justement
on va en parler combien vous avez
parrainage aujourd'hui alors on a à peu
près 300 pas 300 peut-être 350 du jeu je
suis pas au courant des derniers
chiffres parrainage on
ne fanfaronne pas sur cette question là
je vais vous dire c'est compliqué nous
le prenons très au sérieux oui pourquoi
en 2017 il y avait déjà deux tiers des
mères qui n'avaient pas rennais
personnes et là on observe que de plus
en plus de mères ne souhaite pas
parrainer de candidats ce qui pose un
grave problème démocratique et c'est
pourquoi nous avions proposé dès le
début de la candidature de jean luc
mélenchon d'avoir cent cinquante mille
parrainage citoyen qui puisse permettre
à quelqu'un est bien de se présenter ce
que jean luc mélenchon a eu en 48 heures
l'année dernière donc de moins en moins
de maires veulent parrainer notamment
parce qu'ils ont des pressions il
explique que lorsqu'ils ont des
subventions du département de la région
cela les met dans des situations
compliquées et puis la deuxième des
choses c'est que souvent on confond le
parrainage qui est la possibilité
démocratique que des français et des
françaises puissent choisir différents
différents programmes et différentes
options démocratique je verrai avec un
soutien nous nous leur disons au maire
nous ne demandons pas aux mères à qui à
qui revient cette tâche qu'ils ont pas
forcément demandé nous ne demandons pas
aux maires de soutenir la candidature de
jean-luc mélenchon
ce que nous demandons au maire c'est de
permettre à jean luc mélenchon qui avait
récolté 7 millions de voix la dernière
fois avec notre programme l'avenir en
commun d'être candidat est ce que c'est
le fait que tous les parrainages sont
rendus publics aujourd'hui des maires
tous les parrainages de maires sont
rendues publiques désormais est ce que
c'est ça qui pose problème par rapport à
ce qui se faisait en france je pense que
ça contribue aussi au problème mais je
crois que le problème plus profond que
ça et c'est pourquoi nous nous demandons
aussi les 150000 par une hache citoyens
parce que on ne peut pas seulement
laisser les élus parrainer je crois
qu'il est important d'avoir cette
possibilité démocratique aussi pour le
feu pour le financement de la campagne
vous avez des problèmes là aussi au
point oui enfin nous on l'a dit on l'a
dit les banques ne prêtent pas par
ailleurs nous n'avons pas des grands
milliardaires qui nous soutiennent mais
nous avons la chance d'avoir les
millions de gens qui à six et à quoi les
banques ne prêtent pas parce qu'on
serait très bien que jean luc mélenchon
il fera plus de 5% et donc il y aura pas
de problème de remboursement de ce free
continue ça c'est notamment il ya eu
raison profonde il ya il ya eu il ya eu
des propositions qui ont été faites sur
la question des financements des
financements de campagnes sur lequel
tout le monde s'accorde il y avait une
audition il n'y a pas si longtemps que
ça à l'assemblée nationale sur cette
question là avec les trésoriers des
différents mouvements et partis
politiques tous s'accordaient à dire
qu'il y avait un problème y compris du
côté de la république en marge dont il
comptait y compris du côté du de la
majorité présidentielle
donc tant qu'on ne changera pas
ces règles là et bien finalement vous
avez pas répondu à ma question pourquoi
comme j'aime c'est pourquoi à bout du
long qu'est ce qu'il commette justifier
ça je suis ça je ne serai pas vous dire
je ne sais pas pourquoi ils refusent de
prêter mais en tout cas c'est un
problème démocratique qu'un candidat qui
ait un candidat important dans la
présidentielle doivent et bien financé
sa campagne seulement par les dons des
centaines de milliers de soutiens que
nous avons même si évidemment c'est
comme ça que nous le ferons et tous y
voit là et que nous menons campagne et
que nous allons continuer à mener
campagne sur cette question là donc on
va se débrouiller mais ça pose quand
même un problème démocratique qui va au
delà de la candidature de jean luc
mélenchon j'ai jamais donc il faudrait
regarder de près si jean luc mélenchon
qui a prévu de tenir un meeting le 5
décembre prochain un grand meeting de
campagne c'est le jour qu'a choisi
également eric zemmour pour faire son
premier lancement de campagne puisque à
priori ça déclaré candidat si c'est
seulement dans nos primaires de
républicain vous n'êtes pas sympa et
puis journalistes ont fait en deux
semaines par un groupe viennent de fait
c'est un problème pour ouvrir examen
bien sûr c'est un problème
c'est pour ça que jean luc mélenchon
notamment à faire un débat avec lui
parce que je crois qu'on ne peut pas
laisser quelqu'un à l'extrême droite
aussi qu décomplexée qui appellent à la
haine des gens les uns contre les autres
sans aucun contradicteur sans aucune
personne qui redit qu'il existe une
autre france que celle que propose
monsieur zemmour et je crois qu'on a
bien fait à l'heure actuelle marine le
pen plus eric zemmour ça fait plus d'un
tiers de l'électorat alors que vous avez
wes prince qui est là donc tu y vas vous
nommez nom mais qui a fait quelque chose
de courageux sur la question des
sondages non mais ce que nous nous
demandons sur les sondages depuis
longtemps et qu'il ya un point quand
même très important c'est que bon déjà
un les sondages ne font pas une élection
ça c'est la première des choix on est
d'accord mais la deuxième des choses
aujourd'hui bien sûr que s'ils
représentent un électorat mais pas à pas
aussi important que ce que vous ce que
vous dites pourquoi parce que ce que
nous demandons aux instituts de sondage
depuis maintenant des mois c'est que on
indique les taux de participation sur
les sondages or qu'est ce qui se passe
avec beaucoup d institutions l'agent
d'un pays vous demande de 0 à 10 à quel
point êtes-vous prêts à aller voter vous
répondez disent vous êtes sûrs d'aller
voter vous répondez 0 vous êtes sûr de
ne pas aller voter et bien souvent même
si vous répondez 7-8-9 bon je pense que
j'irai mais je suis pas sûr eh bien vous
n'êtes pas comptabilisé dedans donc en
fait il ya un biais extrêmement fort
avec ces sondages là et non l'extrême
droite n'est pas aussi forte dans le
pays oui le peuple français n'a pas
envie de sans trahir a envie qu'on
augmente les salaires envie qu'on change
de constitution pour redéfinir ensemble
les règles du jeu qu'on fasse la
bifurcation écologique et solidaire et
c'est ce que nous faisons avec nos
stratégies de l'union populaire
par les
tours de la présidentielle merci
[Musique]